let's talk about your children you have
two kids yeah they fashion they're very
young right they're very young but
they're both girls yes they love their
girls they love clothes
you know
they're girls
I'm not going to fall into that sexist
trap I
[Applause]
try Kristen Bell I thought you said do
they love fashion and I said yes I don't
know we'll look at the tape later let's
go there's no technology for checking
that out the point is uh you're putting
them in a very narrow box and I think if
a woman can run for president they can
do anything
[Applause]
well anyway what do they what you know
uh they go through this phase when
they're young my kids are a little older
now but when they're they're in their
50s but when my kids were younger they
would go through this phase where they
would just wear the most ridiculous
things yeah and but but still be kind of
like a very special conscious own it
they're not unlike my husband they um
they own it but they you know like my
daughter will wear like a dress she'll
wear her pajama bottoms and then a dress
and then a skirt under tucked up
underneath the dress and then her bikini
bathing suit top over it and it's that's
the only way she's leaving the house and
I have to just send her to school like
that but the only thing that really
Burns about it is that she almost every
day says to me
Mommy why are you not wearing pretty
outfit
really yes so she criticized you
criticizes me because I'm I don't know
just wearing I don't know jeans and like
a white T-shirt but she'll say that to
me and initially my feelings will get
hurt but then I look at her and I'm like
you're a lunatic I can't I can't allow
my feelings to be hurt by a crazy clown
child I remember when my son was two for
a whole day he was walking around
completely naked except for he was
wearing swim goggles and he had a ho a
holster that held a water pistol and he
was wearing one shoe and walking around
like
check it out
this is how we do it oh we have a lot of
photos of it yeah
you uh now do they uh are your kids you
try not to swear around them because
that's a big concern of some parents no
no I too swear
then you're a great mom
[Laughter]
I was swear words
um
where words are because I like we've
talked about what we would say we both
my husband and I both believe that
language has the power that you give it
so if you have feel that those four
letters are going to affect the
situation drastically and offend
everyone then they will but if you don't
then they won't so we've decided to if
they start to swear say you know you
can't do that those are adult words here
are other things you can't do drive my
car vote use the stove you know things
like that right and I thought that was
like a pretty reasonable argument and
they're reasonable kids but the other
day it happened for the first time my
daughter was putting trying to put a
t-shirt on she couldn't get over her
head
and she and she goes mommy I can't get
my t-shirt on
and and really she went right to that
word right to that that's incredible
that's like a kid who's never played the
piano and then
and I was what do you do in that
situation I was just folding laundry and
I just got up and I went and I walked
out of the bedroom and just started
cracking up and she hasn't said it since
right I was too nervous to address it
without that
I think you handled it correctly I
didn't think I'd win the argument yeah
if I were to have to lay out the whole
like you can't drive my car a thing
she'd be like no right I told her to
mentioned this before but there was a
whole year where my son thought that the
f word was Funk and he was like I know
what the f word is and we were like you
do and he went yeah Funk and we were all
and so my wife and I were like yeah
that's the f word but then that song
Uptown Funk came out yeah and we were
like he came in and we were we had it
blasting we were like Uptown Funk up top
by my son was like no
monsters